Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Jürgen Klopp ist dafür bekannt, dass er beim Fußball auf die Details achtet und so ist der FC Liverpool eine Mannschaft, die einen Einwurfcoach beschäftigt. Und mit dem sprechen wir jetzt mit Thomas Gronnemark hier im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Thomas, sehr willkommen im Kurzpass. Hallo, hi. Ja, ich danke dir, dass du mit dabei bist. Du bist Doktor Einwurf, hast du mir gerade noch gesagt.
Mein Name ist Thomas Gronnemark und ich bin Einwurfcoach.
Ja, und darüber musst du mir jetzt ein bisschen was erzählen. Kurz für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die Info. Du kommst aus Dänemark, du bist Däne, du warst aber so freundlich zu sagen, wir probieren das auf Deutsch. Vielen Dank dafür an dich. Das ist ja sicherlich auch nicht das Einfachste. Aber jetzt erklär mir doch mal, wie wird man denn zur Hölle Einwurfcoach?
Ja, ich habe selbst so ungefähr 18, 17, 18 Jahre Fußball gespielt und aber ich war nicht gut genug Profi zu werden. Ich habe weiter zu den Dänische Leichtathletik-Nationalmannschaft, ich habe 100 Meter, 200 Meter, 400 Meter gelaufen und auch Staffel und das hat zugegangen. Aber dann habe ich in 2002 zu Bobsledde gewechselt und ich war 4 Jahre auf der Dänischen Bobsledde-Nationalmannschaft. Und wir haben auch so eine Koversionsbefragung mit dem Deutschen Bobsledden-Verband. Wir haben viele Deutsche gesprochen und es war in der Mitte dieser Periode, dass ich in 2004 gedacht habe, wenn ich so einen Weide-Einwurf machen kann, kann ich auch nicht anders spielen lernen. Ich war zu meiner Hypothese gegangen, aber ich konnte keine Bücher über Weide-Einwürfe finden. Ich habe selbst einen Einwurf-Kurs gemacht und dann nach sechs Monaten habe ich eine lokale Superliga-Mannschaft in Wien gefragt. Sie haben ja gesagt, es war ein großes Erfolg. Sie haben ihren Weide-Einwürfeln viel verbessert. Es war einfach super. Seit vier, fünf Saisonen habe ich normalerweise zwei bis drei professionelle Mannschaften trainiert. Auch Abergöhnung, Jugend und Vorträge. Aber dann hier in diesem Saison trainiere ich momentan sechs verschiedene professionelle Mannschaften hier in Europa.
So ist das gekommen. Da musst du uns gleich noch mehr zu erzählen, auch wie du dann zum FC Liverpool kamst. Aber so ganz habe ich es noch nicht verstanden. Also du hast selbst Fußball gespielt, dann hast du leicht Athletik gemacht, da bist du ja aber vor allem schnell gelaufen. 100, 200, 400 Meter. Dann warst du im Bob-Team, da warst du dann vermutlich Anschieber, denke ich mal. Aber wie kommt man denn dann dazu, Einwurfcoach zu werden? Also wann ist dir denn aufgefallen, dass du besonders weit werfen kannst oder dass das vielleicht ein spannendes Feld für dich sein könnte? Du hältst ja auch den Weltrekord für den längsten Einwurf. Wie kam das?
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber ich habe gewusst, dass ich, als ich selbst gespielt habe, dann habe ich auch schon einen Weitereinwurf gemacht. Ich habe immer gewusst, dass ich ein großer Talent war. Aber damals war es nicht wichtig. Aber wir waren in der dänischen Bobstüdemannschaft, wir waren sehr innovativ und so. Wir haben sehr viele neue Dinge gemacht. Und ich denke, das ist der Grund, weil ich so ab diesem Einwurfcoach-Ding gedacht habe. Für mich war es ganz natürlich.
Und jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, es gab damals noch keine Literatur oder keine anderen Einwurfcoaches. Das heißt, du musstest dir das selbst beibringen. Wie macht man denn das? Hast du dich da an anderen Sportarten orientiert, wo es eben viel häufiger vorkommt, dass man wirft, wenn auch vielleicht mit einer leicht anderen Bewegung?
Ja, du weißt, als ich gesagt habe, habe ich meine eigenen Erfahrungen auf Top-N-Move und Fußball und Leichtathletik und Popsie. Und dann habe ich zum Beispiel auch Basketball gespielt. Und da nehme ich auch sehr viele verschiedene Dinge. Ich versuche immer, Inspiration zu haben von anderen Sportarten und anderen Menschen. Es ist ein spannendes Ding.
Aber dann erklären wir doch mal, was am Einwurf kann man denn überhaupt lernen? Ist es nicht einfach nur den Ball mit beiden Händen über den Kopf werfen und dabei mit beiden Füßen den Boden berühren?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Es gibt ungefähr zwischen 40 und 50 Einwürfe in einem Fußballspiel. Zum Beispiel, wenn Everton gegen Liverpool gespielt hat, da war es 62 Einwürfe. Es gibt sehr viele Situationen. Wenn ich Fußballspieler trainiere, dann trainiere ich in der Weide, der schnelle und der kluge Einwurf. In der Weide kann ich die Spieler weiter werfen. Ich habe ungefähr 25 bis 30 verschiedene technische Varianten. Ich mache auch Videoanalyse und die meisten meiner Spieler verbessern sich zwischen 5 und 10 Metern. Einige auch bis 15 Meter. Viele Spieler in meinen Klubs aktivieren viele Touren von diesen beiden Einwurfen. Dann trainiere ich auch der schnelle Einwurf. der Counterattack Einwurf. Man kann nicht auf einen Einwurf sein. Das ist eine große Waffe. Dann muss man auch schnell den Einwurf machen. Manchmal ist das ein Vorteil und manchmal ist es nicht ein Vorteil. Dann kommt der kluge Einwurf. Wie kann man die Prozesse behalten, wenn man so einen Einwurf unter Druck hat? Ein Einwurf unter Druck ist, wenn alle spielen in Gedechtnis. Die meisten Mannschaften verlieren der Ballen mehr als 50% des Zufalles, wenn sie so einen Einwurf haben. Es ist sehr wichtig, in einem Fußballspiel einen guten Einwurf machen zu können. Wenn du den Ball hast, kannst du eine Tour machen. Wenn der Gegner den Ball kriegt, ist es auch sehr gefährlich. Du weißt, du bist out of balance, auch winzig. In Liverpool haben wir sehr viele Tours gemacht, wenn wir den Ball behalten und den Ball von dem Gegner bekommen haben. Das ist sehr wichtig in einem Fußballspiel.
Es gibt viele Einwürfe pro Spiel, das stimmt. Interessanterweise werden die auch häufig gar nicht so sauber ausgeführt. Du hast es ja selber genannt, in 50 Prozent der Fälle landet der Ball bei einem Einwurf beim Gegner. Ich habe erst gestern mit einem ehemaligen Bundesligaprofi gesprochen, der über 13 Jahre lang Bundesliga gespielt hat. Dem habe ich erzählt von der Sendung, die wir aufnehmen. Da meinte der, er ist klasse. Er fragt sich nämlich schon immer, warum das zum Beispiel im Jugendbereich den Spielern nicht besser beigebracht wird, weil es eben ganz oft unsaubere Einwürfe gibt, dass der Ball nochmal aufspringt, bevor er am Fuß ist, dass er nicht genau in den richtigen Fuß geworfen wird, dass er nicht zielgenau ist. Jetzt erklären wir aber noch ein bisschen. Du hast gesagt, es gibt drei verschiedene Arten von Einwürfen. Es gibt den langen Einwurf, da kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, um was es vergeht, nämlich dass du den Spielern Länge beibringst. Erklär mir mal kurz, was kann man denn da besser machen, um längere Einwürfe zu erzeugen?
Natürlich kann ich nicht alles erzählen, weil das ist mein Job und so. Aber natürlich kann ich ein bisschen sagen. Und ich muss sagen, du weißt auf drei Hauptsachen. Die erste ist der Einlauf. Weil da muss man einen stabilen Einlauf haben mit der richtigen Geschwindigkeit. Und das ist sehr verschieden von Spieler zu Spieler. Dann muss man auch auf der Linie eine gute Position haben. Und dann muss man die Füße richtig stellen. Man muss die Hüfte richtig bringen. Ich sehe auch alle Körperzahlen und so. Und dann muss man auch die Energie richtig über die Linie bringen. Ich habe die letzten 15 Jahre jeden Tag mit mir gearbeitet. Und ich habe zumindest 10.000 oder so Videoanalyse gemacht. Wenn ich einen Fußballspieler sehe, der werft, dann kann ich in fünf Sekunden etwas machen. Das ist Erfahrung. Und das ist egal, wo man in Leben. Wenn man auf eine, ziemlich kleine Dinge fokussiert und auch sehr viel, dann wird man so ein Spezialist. Das ist der Grund, warum ich sehr viele Spieler helfen kann mit diesem langen Einwurf.
Und dann hast du gesagt, es gibt den Einwurf in Umschaltsituationen, also im Konter. Das heißt, es läuft im Konter, der Gegner schafft es irgendwie den Ball über die Auslinie zu grätschen. Dann geht es darum, schnell den Einwurf auszuführen, weil es ja vor allem den regeltechnischen Vorteil gibt. Ein Spieler kann beim Einwurf nicht im Abseits stehen. Das heißt, wenn ich da zielgenau werfen kann, dann habe ich einen enormen Vorteil. Wie gut sind denn Profis dabei zu zielen mit ihrem Einwurf? Ist das das Wichtigste, was du ihnen beibringen musst, oder geht es tatsächlich eher vor allem darum, diese Bewegung schnell und sauber auszuführen?
Nein, alles ist sehr wichtig, weil es auch wichtig ist, einen klügeren Einwurf zu machen. Das ist vielleicht der Wichtigste, weil das ist wichtig für alle Mannschaften in der Welt. Aber ich habe so sehr oft der Außenverteidiger trainiert und auch die Wingers. Da gebe ich nicht nur die Außenverteidiger, aber auch die ganze Mannschaft so ungefähr 7-8 Werkzeuge, die sie meistern sollen. Und dann sollen sie selbst wissen, wann soll ich diesen Werkzeug hier brauchen und wann nicht. Und natürlich, wenn man mit mir anfängt, dann muss man alle die Basics lernen. Und dann, nach einer kurzen Zeit, dann sind sie auch Hochspezialisten wie Liverpool jetzt. Und so, ich will sagen, alles ist wichtig. Weil viele Menschen denken, wenn man so lange Einwürfe trainiert, dann ist es nur, du weißt, Set-Teams und so. Aber alle Teams sollen eine Ausdruckszeige haben, dass lange Einwürfe machen kann. Weil wenn man länger einwirft, dann hast du auch ein großer Einwurfareal. Und wenn du ein großer Einwurfareal hast, dann kannst du mehr Mitspieler werden. Und wenn du so einen sehr kurzen Einwurf hast, dann ist es sehr leichter, so einen Druck auf dir oder der Team zu machen. So ist das für alle Mannschaften.
Ja, das ergibt ja auch Sinn. Und vor allem dann bei der dritten Einwurfart, die du den klugen Einwurf nennst, den cleveren Einwurf, da geht es dann eben darum, der Gegner hat alle Männer zugestellt und jetzt muss man eben quasi in dieser Drucksituation den Ball behalten. Geht es da dann dein Training gar nicht mehr so sehr um die Technik? Also klar, Technik ist wichtig. Aber wie wichtig sind da dann zum Beispiel Laufwege, so ähnlich wie wir es bei Ecken haben, dass eben einer sich kurz anbietet, einer lang, vielleicht auch jemand kreuzt, damit man eben sich so ein bisschen aus dieser Mannendeckung lösen kann?
Ja, ja, ich brauche sehr viel Zeit auf diesen Bewegungen, weil man muss bestimmte Bewegungen machen. Das machen wir sehr viel in meinen Clubs auch. Aber es ist auch, wenn sollen wir schnell werfen, wenn sollen wir warten. Aber es ist auch mit Präzision und so, weil du auch sehr gerne in der Füße werfen musst, weil manchmal ist es auf der Hüfte oder so, oder auf der Brust und das ist nicht gut. Man muss als Fußballspieler und Fußballteam über alles mit der Einwurf arbeiten. Es ist sehr viel zu lernen, aber ich kann auch sehen, dass nach ein oder zwei Trainingsphasen sich die Meister und auch die Teams verbessert haben. So ist es auch ganz leicht zu lernen, aber natürlich muss man auch Zeit aufschätzen.
Woran siehst du, dass sich die Spieler verbessert haben? Beim langen Einwurf ist es mir klar. Da kann man ja einfach sehen, ob jemand weiterwürft als vorher. Und du hast ja gesagt, so 12 bis 15 Meter groß, du da eigentlich aus einem Profi in der Regel immer raus an Länge. Aber wie ist es jetzt bei den anderen beiden Einwurfarten, also beim Konter-Einwurf und beim Einwurf unter Druck?
Ja natürlich werde ich der Prozentzahl messen, mit zum Beispiel Prozessen und so, wie viele Bälle behalten wir, wie viele Bälle kriegt der Gegner. Und das sehe ich, aber es ist nicht nur eine Zahl, es ist auch, du weißt, subjektiv auch, weil manchmal kannst du der Gegner einen Ball nehmen, aber manchmal weißt du einen sehr guten Einwurf oder eine sehr gute Bewegung. Und auch umgekehrt, manchmal behält man einen Ball, aber dann hat man es nicht so gut gemacht, du weißt, mit der Bewegung und so, Präzision. So ist es immer so, du weißt, man muss auf verschiedene Toppen drehen und so, und dann soll es sehr gerne besser und besser sein werden. Das ist auch, was ich in der verschiedenen Gruppe sehe.
So ein bisschen deine Philosophie. Dann erzähl mir doch mal, wie bist du zum FC Liverpool bekommen? Hat Jürgen Klopp dein Weltrekord-Video gesehen und hat gesagt, ach, das will ich auch, dass jemand mit einem Flickflack über 50 Meter weit wirft, oder wie kam das?
Das ist ein kleines Spaßgeschichte hier, aber ich war hier Anfang Juli 2018 mit meiner Familie. Wir haben so eine kleine Urlaubsbahn gemacht, und da haben wir auf eine Schokolade-Poutique gestoppt, und da habe ich auf mein Telefon angeguckt, und es war auch geräuschlos. Und dann habe ich gesehen, dass ein Plus-44-Nummer angerufen hat, und wenn man so eine Firma wie mir hat, dann weiß man auch, dass vielleicht jemand mit mir telefonieren will, um uns zu kugelschreiben, zu verkaufen oder so. So ist es manchmal, und dann habe ich auf mein Telefon gehört, wer hat anrufen und dann weiß Jürgen Klopp auf der Telefon.
Der, der Kugelschreiber verkaufen wollte.
Ja, nein, überhaupt nicht. Er hat nur gefragt, ob ich weiter anrufen könnte, und dann habe ich probiert, aber er hat nicht das Telefon genommen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ich will nur zu Hause fahren mit meiner Familie nachher, und dann, du weißt, in so eine ruhige Umgebung, der ein wichtiges Telefon aufnehmen kann. Und dann haben wir zu Hause gefahren, und dann habe ich, ich habe das Haus gefahren, und meine Frau hat neben mir gesetzt. Aber dann plötzlich hat der Telefon geklingelt, und dann hat meine Frau das Telefon genommen, und dann haben sie gesagt, es ist Jürgen. Und dann habe ich so, dann habe ich das Auto direkt auf so ein Grasfeld eingefahren, und dann habe ich in der Mitte auf so ein Grasfeld in Dänemark mit Jürgen Klopp gesprochen. Und dann, ja, dann hat er mir gefragt, ob ich nächste Woche auf Millwood kommen will, mit so einem Meeting, weil er hat gesagt, dass letzte Saison haben wir eine gute Saison, mit einem Viertelplatz und Champions League Finale. Aber der Eingriff, sie war sehr schlecht, weil sie haben immer den Ball verloren. Und er hat gesagt, dass er etwas probiert, aber es hat nicht funktioniert. Und ja, er hat nicht gewusst, was zu tun. Aber dann hat er so einen Artikel in der Bild gelesen über mir. Und dann hat er mir angerufen. Der Woche nachher habe ich zu Millwood gekommen. Und es war eigentlich nur ein kleiner Meeting, aber er war so überzeugt, Jürgen, dass ich, der Tag nachher habe ich 21 Spieler von Liverpool trainiert, von der Premier League Mannschaft. Für alle die Spieler, die nicht verletzt waren oder auf Urlaub oder auf der Welt kamen. Und dann nachher habe ich so einen Vertrag gekriegt bis 31.12.2018. Und dann haben sie hier in der Herbstvertrag verlängert bis 30. Juni. Und ja, für mich war es wie ein Abenteuer. Einmal ein großes Traum war immer so in der Premier League zu trainieren. Es ist fantastisch.
Und dann gleich beim FC Liverpool und Jürgen Klopp. Ruf bei sowas noch persönlich an, das ist doch interessant. Jetzt würde mich aber interessieren, wie haben denn dann die Spieler auf dich reagiert? Du wirst ja ziemlich wahrscheinlich der erste Einwurfcoach in ihrer Karriere gewesen sein. Konnten die gleich verstehen, dass das eine wichtige Sache ist? Haben das nicht alle gleich ernst genommen? Wie sind die dir begegnet?
Ja, ich will erst sagen, wenn einige so ein bisschen lächeln und so, das ist kein Problem für mir, weil ich weiß, das ist Einwurftrainer oder Einwurfcoach. Das ist ein merkwürdiges Jobtitel, das weiß ich. Aber ich probiere immer, dass die Trainer nur auf die Spieler eine Meinung so geben. In der Anfang in Liverpool habe ich gesagt, normalerweise sind es zwischen 40 und 50 Einwürfe. Ich habe auch gesagt, es ist nicht meine Ziel, ihr zu Stoke Nr. 2 zu machen.
Also die besonders lange Einwürfe machen.
Ja, die haben sehr, sehr viele lange Einwürfe gemacht. Aber ich habe gesagt, dass die meisten Mannschaften verlieren den Ball, wenn sie so einen Einwurf ohne Druck haben, mehr als 50% der Zufälle. Und wenn man diesen Zähler hört, dann ist es eigentlich wahnsinnig nicht etwas zu tun, weil es ist so viel in einem Fußballspiel. Ich denke, die Spieler sind sehr positiv. Jürgen hat mehrmals auf einer Pressekonferenz etwas positiv gesagt, auch Andy Robertson, vor einer Pressekonferenz in der Scottish National. Die Trainer sind sehr zufrieden. Sie lieben auch, was wir in einem Spiel tun. Sie sehen, dass wir im Vergleich zu den Champions League-Mannschaften viel besser sind.
Hast du da Zahlen? Weißt du, wie viel Prozent der Ball nach eigenem Einwurf gehalten wird? Von 50 Prozent auf? Normalerweise.
Das ist mein Zähler. Manchmal ist es subjektiv, weil man nicht nur sagen kann, wann der Ball gehalten wird. Ist das Sekunden oder Berührungen? Aber mit meinen Zählern haben wir Prozesse in Liverpool zwischen 75 und 100 Prozent. Zum Beispiel haben wir das erste Champions League-Spiel gegen Bayern München. Da waren wir unter unserer eigenen normalen Zustand. Da haben wir es nur in ungefähr 65 Prozent in der Einrufe untergebracht. Aber dann haben die Bayern München den Ball nur in so ungefähr 28 Prozent behalten. Ja, das ist ein großer Unterschied. Das ist natürlich ein großer Vorteil, als ich es gesagt habe. Vorher aber, wenn du den Ball hast, dann kannst du ein Tor machen. Wenn der Gegner es kriegt, dann ist es oft sehr gefährlich, weil du bist out of balance.
Also in der Tat hat man das im Hinspiel gesehen. Wir hatten schon vorher Kontakt. Ich wusste schon, dass wir diese Sendung machen. Da habe ich natürlich auf jeden Einwurf im Hinspiel ganz genau geachtet. Und es war tatsächlich zu sehen, dass Liverpool da viel häufiger den Ball behalten hat, auch wenn sie ihn dennoch hin und wieder verloren haben. Aber bei Bayern ist es mir auch aufgefallen, dass der Ball in der Regel weg war, weil es eben auch schwierig ist, den Ball zu verarbeiten, wenn man mit dem Rücken zum Spielfeldinneren steht. Das ist ja die normale Art und Weise, wie man einen Einwurf annimmt. Und das war nicht das Beste. Da hat man schon zumindest einen Unterschied zwischen beiden Mannschaften gesehen. Würdest du denn sagen, ist der beste Einwerfer beim FC Liverpool?
Das kommt auch an, was man auf den besten Einwerfer denkt. Aber lasst mir zwei verschiedene nennen. Das ist erstmal Joe Gomez. Er wirft jetzt 37,20 Punkte in einen Test. Er hat einen der besten Einwürfe in der Welt, denke ich. Er hat auch eine Einwurfchor assistiert in der Länderspiel zwischen England und Kroatien. Aber wir machen nicht sehr viele weitere oder lange Einwürfe in Liverpool, weil das ist nicht unsere Spielart. Und dann will ich auch einen anderen, wir haben sehr viele gute Einwürfe auf Liverpool, zum Beispiel Andy Robertson oder Robbo. Er ist ein bisschen wie der Pirlo von den Einwürfen oder so. Ja, ja, weil er hat erstmal, er weiß präzise, wenn zu werfen, wenn zu warten. Er kann auch mit sehr guter Präsentation werfen, aber er macht auch manchmal einen Trick, Einwürfen und so. Und er kann alle, er ist unglaublich, gut denke ich. Aber er werft nicht so weit wie Jürgen Klopp, aber für mich ist es auch nicht der wichtigste, der beste in der Welt oder der beste in England oder Deutschland zu werden, mit der Weile. Weil, ich denke, es ist fast mehr wichtig, dass du auch präzise werfen kannst. Und du weißt auch, wenn deine Mitspieler unter Druck oder nicht unter Druck sind. Das ist der beste Einwürfer von Liverpool.
Der Pirlo des Einwurfs, sehr schön. Das habe ich mir gemerkt. Wer ist denn dann der Messi des Einwurfs im Weltfußball? Also wer ist der beste Einwerfer auf der Welt deiner Meinung nach?
Das ist schwer zu sagen. Wenn man so einen langen Einwurf macht, dann ist es sehr wichtig, dass es nicht nur weit oder lang ist. Aber es ist auch flach und schnell. Das ist auch mit der Technik. Ich trainiere ja auch FC Midtjylland in Dänemark, der Superliga-Mannschaft. Hansen von FC Midtjylland hat in den letzten drei Saisonen ungefähr 25 Toren assistiert mit dem Weiter-Einwurf. Er hat eine sehr super und saubere Technik. Letztes Jahr hat er in FC Midtjylland zehn Toren mit dem Weiter-Einwurf gemacht, und sie war Dänische Meister. Für mich ist es sehr wichtig zu sagen, dass ich Einwurfs zu trainieren, nicht mit so vielen langen Einwurfs zu machen, weil ich habe sehr viele Mannschaften, die nicht lange Einwurfs machen, wie Liverpool, Leipzig und so. Alle Mannschaften können das machen. Wir müssen nur die richtige Wissen haben und die richtige Übung.
Und es geht eben nicht nur immer darum, ein Tor zu erzielen durch Anwurf, das ist ja klar. Dann sag mir mal, du trainierst auch einen Bundesligisten oder berätst einen Bundesligisten, den du aber geheim hältst. Magst du uns nicht wenigstens einen Tipp geben, wer das sein könnte? Oder du kannst es jetzt hier auch exklusiv sagen.
Nein, ich denke, das ist nicht richtig. Vielleicht später, vielleicht in der Zukunft. Aber das ist richtig. Ich habe in dieser Saison an Bundesligamannschaften geholfen. Und ja, so ist es. Vielleicht sage ich es später oder so. Aber ich trainiere zwei Profi-Mannschaften in Dänemark, auch an Bundesligamannschaften, an Liverpool FC, und auch zwei Vereine in Belgium. Und hier ist der eine Gänt von der Ersten Liga.
Ist der Bundesligist aktuell unter den ersten sechs? Also Dortmund, Bayern, Leipzig, Gladbach, Frankfurt oder Leverkusen. War er da dabei?
Das kann ich ja natürlich nicht sagen. Es ist keine Konkurrenz oder so. Ich kann nur sagen, es ist eine Bundesligamannschaft. Und natürlich will ich sehr gerne allen helfen. Und es ist egal, ob es die Premier League oder Bundesliga oder vielleicht in der Zukunft eine Liga oder Australien oder Brasilien oder USA oder so.
Okay, dann lasse ich dich da auch auf jeden Fall von der Leine. Das muss man ja respektieren. Was glaubst du denn? Jetzt weiß man, dass es dich gibt und gerade jetzt die Zusammenarbeit mit dem FC Liverpool hat das ganze Thema auch ein bisschen bekannter gemacht. Glaubst du, dass sich im modernen Fußball jetzt mehr Mannschaften mit Einwürfen auseinandersetzen? Gibt es vielleicht schon erste kleine Thomas Gronnemarks, die jetzt auch sich darin spezialisieren? Glaubst du, das wird sich ein bisschen verändern jetzt in der näheren Zukunft?
Das hoffe ich, weil der Qualität von den Einwürfen im Weltfußball sehr schlecht ist. Und ich denke, es wird Fußball besser machen. Es wird auch mehr Unterhaltung geben, weil wir auch nicht schlechte Pisse mit den Füßen sehen. In der Mitte des Spielfelds. Natürlich kann es niemals perfekt werden, aber kann man der Qualität hören, so dass es auch schneller geht und mehr präzise geht, dann ist es besser für den Fußball. Natürlich hoffe ich, dass nicht nur mir selbst mehr Fußball bereiten hat, sondern auch andere Menschen hier machen, weil ich nicht alle 2 Trillionen Fußballbereiten in der Welt trainiere. Ich will natürlich auch nächste Saison mehr Vereine helfen. Es ist auch wichtig für mich zu sagen, dass ich viele Dinge da auch, du trainierst nur Premier League und Bundesliga und so, aber manchmal trainiere ich auch Jugend und ich trainiere auch Amateure. Zum Beispiel mit Deutschland, ich lebe in Dänemark. Das ist in der Nähe so, wenn ein Amateur oder Jugendverein sagt, wir wollen sehr gerne Thomas investieren, dann tun wir das. Das mache ich auch in Dänemark zu. So ist es nicht, ich kann nur die Große trainieren. Ja, ja, ich denke, es ist immer spannend.
Und wird es nicht irgendwann langweilig, sich immer nur mit Einwürfen zu beschäftigen? Du machst das jetzt, vorhin hast du gesagt, schon seit 15 Jahren?
Nein, es ist nicht langweilig, weil da ist so viel verschiedene Dinge hier mit den Einwürfen. Als ich gesagt habe, mit der langen, der schnellen und der kluge Einwürfe, dann hat man so viele verschiedene Dinge zu machen. Und ja, das ist kein Problem, es ist nicht langweilig.
Na gut, dass du das sagst, so ganz verwundert es mich ja auch nicht. Dann jetzt letzte Frage. Wir nehmen auf, natürlich vor dem Rückspiel von Bayern gegen Liverpool, werden wir ein Tor nach langem Einwurf sehen. Jetzt kannst du es prognostizieren.
Nein, das denke ich nicht. Und es ist auch nicht wichtig für mich. Für mich aber auch. Und dann wollen einige vielleicht sagen, ist das nicht gut? Aber zum ersten, da machen wir keine sehr viele Weide- oder lange Einwürfe. Und es ist nicht, weil wir nicht können, so vielleicht machen wir es. Aber für mich ist es wichtig, dass wir gut auf diesem Prozess sind und den Ball behalten und nehmen. Und für mich ist Einwurf mehr so eine Philosophie. Es ist ein Teil in einem Fußballspiel. Normalerweise sind 40 bis 50 Mal in einem Fußballspiel. Es ist nicht ein kleiner Ding. Wenn man diesen Übung oder Einwurf beherrscht, dann hat man einen großen Vorteil im Vergleich zu einem Team, der es nicht beherrscht. Ich sage nicht, dass auch meine Teams hier einig sein können, aber normalerweise sind wir besser im Vergleich und manchmal auch viel besser. Ich denke, das ist dein Vorteil.
Das glaube ich. Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass ich mich über eine halbe Stunde nur über Einwürfe unterhalten würde. Aber es ist gleichzeitig komisch, dass man das noch nicht getan hat. Du sagst es eben, es kommt häufiger vor als Ecken, es kommt häufiger vor als Flanken. Es ist sehr häufig im Fußballspiel zu beobachten und es kann sich noch einiges verbessern. Das war Thomas Gronnemark, Einwurfcoach beim FC Liverpool und einem geheim gehaltenen Bundesligisten. Bei Twitter kann man dir folgen als thomasthrowin. Thomas, vielen Dank, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk. Ich wünsche dir eine gute Zeit in Liverpool. Ich wünsche uns allen ein schönes Rückspiel. Sollten wir das denn jetzt hier vor dem Rückspiel noch hören? Lieben Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das war Kurzpass Nummer 121. Folgt Thomas auf Twitter, at thomasthrowin ohne das G hinten dran. Ich werde es aber auch nochmal verlinken. Und unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr mir eure Einwurftheorien präsentieren. Ich freue mich auf Feedback. Habt eine gute Zeit. Bis zum nächsten Mal im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut. Ciao.